une nouvelle hauteur va faire son
apparition sur les enveloppes des
français un timbre à l'effigié de
l'écrivaine elsa triolet a été dévoilée
pour marquer les 50 ans de sa
disparition une présentation dans la
propriété de l'artiste à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines elle rejoint
son époux louis aragon qui avait eu son
timbre en 1991
au total 480 15000 exemplaires seront
tirés une édition limitée disponible
dans deux mille bureaux de poste depuis
le lundi 14 juin
ce qu'on annonce une un tirage ce thème
sera en vente pendant 12 mois et qu'il
soit vendu ou non à la fin il sera de
toutes façons retiré du marché la
demande date l'été 2010 9 et fait
l'objet d'une confirmation en septembre
cette demande a été formulée par la
direction de la maison elsa triolet
aragon
né en 1896 elle s'est engagée dans la
résistance pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale elle a écrit une trentaine
d'ouvragés et en 1945 elle à triolet a
récompensé du prix goncourt pour son
titre le premier accroc coûte 200 francs
c'est un nom qui est connu mais souvent
il n'ya que ce nom qui est connu et
entonner - l'heure parce qu'on connaît
son nom à travers aragon alors qu'on
n'est pas toujours aller jusqu à la
lecture de cette oeuvre est une grande
oeuvre et on voulait saisir l'occasion
cet anniversaire poursuit piquer la
curiosité on est certain que ceux qui
seront suffisamment curieux pour ouvrir
les pages en ouvrirons d'autres pour la
première femme à avoir obtenu le prix
goncourt ce timbre est un véritable
hommage une mise en lumière pour le 51e
anniversaire de la disparition d'elsa
triolet
elle a quitté ce monde le 16 juin 1970